بينما يبدأ الرئيس جو بايدن
حملته الانتخابية للدورة الانتخابية المقبلة،
لم يعد قادرًا على تجاهل
الدعوات المتزايدة لدعم وقف إطلاق النار في
غزة، والآن يرفض بعض القادة العرب الأمريكيين
في ولاية ميشيغان المتأرجحة الرئيسية
الاجتماع مع  حملته، إذا
كنت تحترمنا بالفعل
وتكرمنا كبشر،
فلا ترسل طاقم الحملة للحديث عن
مثل هذه القضية الملحة الآن، فالمحادثة الوحيدة التي
نهتم بها
هي تلك التي تدور حول
وقف إطلاق النار الذي قرره بايدن  اعترف
بالاحتجاج المتزايد حول هذه القضية، وأنا
أتفهم شغفهم
وأعمل بهدوء، لقد كنت أعمل بهدوء مع
الحكومة الإسرائيلية لحملها على
تقليص حجمها والخروج بشكل كبير من غزة،
لكنني لا أزال أواجه ردود فعل عنيفة بسبب دعمه
لإسرائيل.  تحدث إلى القادة الأمريكيين العرب
والمسلمين الذين يقولون إنهم لن
يدعموا إعادة انتخاب بايدن، ليس هذا فحسب،
بل إنهم يرفضون بشدة
الاجتماعات مع فريقه، حتى أن هناك
حملة وطنية بدأها
الأمريكيون المسلمون للتخلي عن بايدن في الولايات المتأرجحة الرئيسية
مثل مينيسوتا وفلوريدا.  جورجيا
وميشيغان سوف نتأكد من أننا
نذهب ونصوت ولكن لن نصوت له، فهذا
مهم في الأماكن التي
قد يعني فيها الفوز بأصوات المسلمين الفوز بالولاية بأكملها
مثل ميشيغان حيث تغلب بايدن على
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بما يزيد قليلاً عن
150 ألف صوت في عام
2020 وهناك  كان هناك أكثر من 200.000
ناخب أمريكي مسلم مسجل في
ميشيغان في ذلك العام، وخرج أكثر من 145.000
للتصويت وفقًا لمنظمة
متخصصة في
حشد الناخبين المسلمين، وهي
كتلة من الناخبين الذين كانوا موالين
للحزب الديمقراطي منذ سنوات
وليسوا عادةً  ناخبو الحزب الواحد
هنا، هذه هي قضيتهم الوحيدة على الرغم من أن
هذه هي قضيتهم الوحيدة وهي أنهم
سيذهبون إلى صناديق الاقتراع، حيث
يشعر المجتمع بأنهم غير إنسانيين لدرجة أنه
لا يتم رؤيتهم، ولذا فإننا
نناشد حقًا الاعتراف بالمخاوف
والاحتياجات أه  مشاعر هذا المجتمع
كلما أسرعت في الدعوة إلى وقف إطلاق النار كلما زاد
الوقت المتاح للعمل على إيصال
المجتمع إلى وضع يمكنهم من خلاله
دعم أه الرئيس جو بايدن في
السباق حتى الآن حملة إعادة انتخاب بايدن
لم يتم اعتمادها من قبل أي مسلم  أو
المجموعات العربية الأمريكية
والأصوات المؤثرة من محاولته الأخيرة ظلت
صامتة مثل الديموقراطية رشيدة طالب من
ميشيغان، أول امرأة أمريكية من أصل فلسطيني
تعمل في الكونغرس في عام 2020،
وحثت ولايتها على التصويت لصالح بايدن ولكن
على الرغم من أنها التقت
بمدير حملة بايدن ت.  لم يشر
إلى تأييد ترشيحه هذه المرة،
وبدلاً من ذلك دعا الحزب إلى
وقف إطلاق النار في الشرق الأوسط بينما
اتهم الرئيس بدعم
الإبادة الجماعية للفلسطينيين، السيد الرئيس،
الشعب الأمريكي ليس معك في هذه
القضية التي سنتذكرها في
عام 2024.